adele reveals a private conversation she
had with beyonce at the 2017 grammys
after her album 25 won album of the year
over beyonce's lemonade at music's
biggest night my album of year is
lemonade um
she is my
icon of my whole life in the november
2021 issue of vogue the hello singer
explains that she wholeheartedly thought
beyonce should have won and she assumed
queen bee would win until the award show
started quote i just got this feeling i
won it i got overwhelmed with like i
will have to go and tell her how much
her record means to me absolutely yeah
adele took home five grammys that night
while beyonce won best urban
contemporary album and best music video
and during adele's album of the year
acceptance speech she let her feelings
be known my artist of my life is beyonce
in this album for me the lemonade album
was just
so monumental beyonce it was so
monumental
after finishing her speech she also
opened up about it backstage like i said
in my speech for me my album of the year
was lemonade um so
a piece of me did die inside as a
beyonce stan i'm not gonna lie um
because i was completely rooting for her
i feel like it was her time to win
obviously the visual is very
new and you know it's and the grammys
are very traditional but i just thought
this year
um would be the year that they would
kind of go with the tides um and i am of
course very very grateful having won
here um but i felt the need because i
love her because um
i felt like she was more than worthy and
years later recalling the whole thing
still makes her emotional she tells
vogue that after the ceremony she went
to beyonce's dressing room twice to tell
her how much the lp meant to her quote i
just said to her like the way that the
grammys works and the people who control
it at the very very top they don't know
what a visual album is they don't want
to support the way that she's moving
things forward with her releases and the
things that she's talking about
[Music]
yourself
don't play yourself
and when asked why she believes lemonade
deserved to win she explains quote for
my friends who are women of color it was
such a huge acknowledgement for them of
the sort of undermined grief that they
go through for her to nail that on the
head and also bring in the entire globe
i was like this album is my album she
just knows what i'm going through that
album was not written for me but yet i
could still feel like this is the
biggest gift
adele adds that beyonce's music was a
major part of her childhood explaining
that as an only child music became her
companion quote that's why i love
beyonce so much she would put out music
so regularly it would be like seeing her
it really felt like that for me it made
me feel a lot of things it's been a
complete whirlwind now adele is gearing
up for the release of her new music
she shared that teaser clip for her new
single easy on me which is set to drop
on october 15th
fans speculate that the song will be
featured on her upcoming album which is
rumored to be titled 30.
you